you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
sunset the Tenenbaum what in walks a
little friend Emily bonk now Paul kiss a
little fella and needless to say we did
have to stack a few stools on top of
each other for him to reach the bar but
he got there okay Danny look I'm a
sadness
what's wrong
well just chocolate home you know and I
want starts it well I think one but to
kill and they said yeah my wife my wife
she's she's been giving me real trouble
I said oh really
they said
she's just been bunking everybody
excuse me
she's just been bunking everybody and I
said earlier that that is a problem how
many be my she been thinking laces up
just too many to count
I mean it's basically people she doesn't
like blah so will she
she's bulky
she doesn't like I said yeah nothing
there's some sort of weird psychological
issue that says no no no that makes
complete sense to me it's not that
complicated she doesn't like the person
she box him not said well sounds
complicated to me but whatever not my
affair so Muhsin this is bunking around
this this disturbs you
not first but just been bunking too many
people I mean it's gonna be given a
headache after a while and also giving
her headache what about you you must
have up a mic waiting over there
certainly so I wasn't too bad at first
but now it's just getting low annoying
especially once you started doing the
animals
awesome she started bunking animals I
said oh yeah
dinosaurs mostly we've mostly been
around dinosaurs I said so
your wife's been bunking people and
dinosaurs
yeah little diner soon is a big one oh
no no no real big ones it's impressive
how many big dinosaur sugarpop I mean
it's just unbelievable and I said oh no
I can barely get my head around it
myself
oh you mean like tier axes and stuff
like that he says oh yeah
you're better off but I'll ask doesn't
that hurt her and he said well the
harder ones yeah but the really soft
ones the ones are much softer scared
that'sthat's not as big a problem
drugs it's all set have you thought
about going to the couples counseling I
said I could but you know we get down to
it
I've bought just as many people
also Willie I said yeah I'll say
dinosaurs - it says oh yeah giant wants
great big ones you'll have no idea how
hard it is to get up there nurse I can
imagine I can imagine so you're both
bulking people and dinosaurs at the same
time he says yeah I first I don't have a
problem with it but I think it's just
getting out of hand
what's the main says act other one blow
my own horn but I give the right head
now said okay stop it stop it
I slamming like nobody's business I need
a slapping heart they're barely able to
open their arms act on done with them I
said okay TMI TMI as I decide to pry
probably where I should cry but lord
knows he only has and I said how often
do you Tupac makes us I told you all the
time I said no no together
I mean the two of us Bogue each other
this is another always supposed to
Nelson
is one of the perks of being in a
relationship I mean what's the point of
bonking other people if you're not gonna
bonk each other this is looking better
for the Lord knows I don't want her
bunking other people when it's not
needed and I said you you've built other
people when it's needed he says yeah
only one that's needed
thou shalt not talk unless needed I
think that's the 11th commandment if all
feels somebody is not worth a bunk
I will not want them I said well that no
kind of you I guess
he said uncle Punk you will good I'll
say okay okay don't go on just don't
says I can give you a head like nobody's
business I said okay do not go okay you
do not want to cross this line they said
okay okay but needless to say you would
be out like a light I said thanks thanks
I believe you
so I just flat-out asked I said well
have you thought about talking huh he
says well okay now
says she's given herself a concussion
she said hospital right now they don't
know when she's gonna wake up and I said
oh not them Punk
I'll get it now I get it now okay now on
the same page and I'm so sorry about
that he said it was really hard seeing
her then just sleeping unable to
communicate so she practically looked
like an angel absolutely beautiful
mr. Barroso saw him since I do you offer
places needless to say when she wakes up
by a proper coat Demelza NASA divorce
her why he says she her reaping
that warps Clell strange things as a
bartender Simona strange things at the
palace so I'll see a lot of strange
it's a palace
you